welcome to horace hobbies the channel
will be discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest tech products
today we're taking a look at how the GPU
price drop that is coming later this
month is actually just desperate temper
Nvidia to try and save themselves from
the sticky situation that they are in
right now but before we delve into that
make sure hit that subscribe button if
you want to stay updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs so
as you guys all know GPU priced have
been in place for quite a while now due
to the extra demand problem by
cryptocurrency miners and the effects of
RAM prices and stocks shortages however
at this point the cryptocurrency mining
GPU demand is almost non-existent
because most crypto currencies are even
doing well in the first place and on top
of that it is getting hard to mine them
and most big-name crypto currencies have
a 6-2 mined them which makes GPU mining
completely pointless and as for RAM
prices in the past we have seen how RAM
prices don't really affect GPU prices in
the past we have seen how RAM prices
haven't really affected GPU crisis at
all
for example in the holiday season of
last year GPU prices were well below
MSRP but RAM prices were just as bad as
they are right now so as we can see GPU
prices aren't really affected by RAM
prices so as a result for the past two
months there has really been nothing
holding back GPUs from MSRP but despite
that GPU prices have been going down at
such a slow rate if you're interested in
the details of why this exactly
happening
they make sure to check out my dedicated
video on this phenomenon but long story
short our willingness to overpay for
GPUs is what is allowing NVIDIA and
retailers to pull off such outrageous
pricing it is not that Nvidia is selling
more GPUs than they were before because
indeed their sales are much lower it's
just that the profit that they make on
each one is so much higher because of
the high price they charge so in the end
their overall revenue and profit is
indeed higher but their sales are not as
high as before so make sure not to
confuse
hi profit and revenue with their sales
mount while this may have been working
for them for several weeks in the long
run this may have gotten them into a big
problem
NVIDIA has been telling us for almost
six months now that they are working
very hard to crank up production and we
know the invidious sales aren't doing
nearly as well as they were before
especially because of the increased
anticipation for the 1100 series and so
if NVIDIA isn't lying so what is
happening with all those GPUs well
apparently all of them have ended up
back at Nvidia a Taiwanese om supposedly
returned three hundred thousand GPUs
backed Nvidia not because there were any
defects or anything wrong with it but
because they just didn't think they'd
sell that many and this is the only one
that made it onto the news so who knows
if other added board partners like MSI
you get by asus and EVGA also returned
to GPUs back to Nvidia well whether they
did or not
apparently NVIDIA has over 1 million 10
series GPUs just sitting in their
inventory right now so ask for business
you can sell a small amount of items for
a really high price with high profit
margins or you can sell a lot of that
item for a really cheap price and lower
profit margins and in the end you would
make about the same revenue in profit
and since in vs so much stock of the 10
series and since the 1100 series is set
to launch quite soon this is most likely
why there's a lot of hype surrounding a
huge price drop coming later this month
it is simply because NVIDIA needs to get
rid of all these GPUs while the 10
series is still relevant and popular so
in essence the GPU price drop that is
coming is really just a ploy by Nvidia
to deal with their excess inventory and
this is probably why the gtx 1100 series
hasn't been announced yet because nvidia
probably wanted some way to announce
something that will reduce consumers
willingness to buy the ten series
anymore because they have so much
inventory and they need to get rid of it
before releasing the 1100 series so
that's the truth behind the upcoming
price drop but whatever the motive is
for it you're still saving money so
should you take
advantage of it and biotin series card
right now well really whenever I tell
you guys to buy something or not I just
look at the value that you were getting
for the money you were spending and I
really don't know how low GPU prices
will go right now but here in the
situation that I expect if price is just
hit MSRP or their twenty to thirty
dollars lower than MSRP then oh just
don't buy it because the 1100 series
equivalent are coming about very soon
for the same MSRP and the twenty eight
thirty dollars that you would save
Israel and this is not the time to be
saving that type of money because you
would be getting so much more
performance with the 1100 series however
if you guys find a really good deal as
over $50 preferably even over 70 or $80
and you guys are completely satisfied
with the performance that you would be
getting then yes you should just go
ahead and buy it but otherwise you guys
should really just wait because the 1100
series is really just around the corner
and this is just more proof the 1100
series is coming out because usually all
most outdated products have huge
discounts and deals before the new
series comes out but that is just what I
think what do you guys think are you
guys furious that in-video is able to
pull off such outrageous pricing for
such a long time or do you not really
care because you were going to buy the
1100 series anyways make sure comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments that I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video then make sure drop a
like and hit that subscribe button if
you guys like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye
you